J'aimerais parler des tendances technologiques,
c'est ce que beaucoup d'entre vous suivent -
mais que nous suivons aussi, pour des raisons similaires.
Évidemment, en tant que magazine technologique, les tendances technologiques
sont des choses sur lesquelles nous écrivons et que nous devons connaître.
nais c'est aussi qu'en tant que mensuel -
vous vivez dans le futur. Et nous avons un prévisionnel très lointain.
Nous devons planifier les sorties de longs mois à l'avance,
nous devons deviner ce que seront les intérêts du public dans six mois,
dans neuf mois à venir. Donc nous sommes dans le business des prévisions.
Nous aussi, comme beaucoup de sociétés, nous créons un produit.
qui est basé sur les tendances technologiques.
Dans notre cas, il s'agit d'idées et d'informations, et si nous avons de la chance,
un peu de divertissement. Mais le concept est presque le même.
Et donc nous devons comprendre
pas seulement pourquoi la techno est importante, où elle va,
mais aussi, très important : quand - l'instant fait la différence.
Et c'est intéressant, quand vous regardez les prédictions faites
pendant le pic du boom des années 90, au sujet de l'e-commerce,
ou le trafic internet, ou l'adoption du haut débit, ou la publicité sur internet,
ils avaient tous raison - ils s'étaient juste trompés de moment.
Pratiquement chacune de ces annonces s'est réalisée juste quelques années plus tard.
Mais la différence de quelques années sur la valorisation boursière
est, à l'évidence, extrême. Et c'est pourquoi l'instant fait toute la différence.
Vous avez vraisemblablement vu quelque chose de similaire auparavant.
Ceci est la courbe classique Gartner Hype, qui montre
une sorte de trajectoire de la vie d'une technologie.
Et juste pour l'exemple, nous y avons mis un tas de technologies,
pour montrer si elles allaient s'élever vers le premier pic,
on si elles allaient s'écraser
dans le fossé de la désillusion,
ou se relever sur la pente de l'illumination, ou - etc.
Et c'est une manière de faire de la prévision sur les technologies, comprendre
où se tient la technologie, et ensuite anticiper le prochain virage.
Nous le faisons pour toute technologie qui nous semble suffisamment importante,
nous allons le faire deux fois. D'abord, nous voulons être les premiers.
Nous voulons être les premiers à le faire, pour les geeks qui l'apprécient,
nous allons la saisir justement au démarrage.
Vous pouvez voir en 1997, nous mettons Linux en couverture.
Mais après ça revient. Et des technologies suffisamment importantes
vont toucher le grand public et elles vont exploser.
Et c'est le moment de recommencer. L'année dernière.
Et c'est une manière pour nous d'historiciser les tendances technologiques.
J'aimerais parler d'une manière de penser les tendances technologiques
que j'appelle ma grande théorie unifiée de prédiction du futur,
mais c'est plus proche d'une petite théorie unifiée de prédiction du futur.
C'est basé sur la supposition, l'observation même,
que toutes les technologies importantes traversent quatre phases dans leur vie -
au moins une de ces phases, parfois les quatre phases.
Et chaque phase peut être vue comme une collision -
une collision avec quelque chose d'autre -
par exemple, un prix critique déterminant qui change en même temps
la technologie et ses effets dans le monde. C'est un point d'inflexion.
Et ce sont ces points d'inflexion qui vous diront
quel sera le prochain chapitre dans la vie de cette technologie.
et peut-être comment vous pouvez en faire quelque chose.
Le premier est le prix critique.
La première phase dans l'avancée d'une technologie
est qu'elle tombera sous un prix plancher.
Une fois qu'elle est tombée sous un prix critique, elle va tendre,
si c'est un succès, à s'élèver au-dessus d'une masse critique, d'un taux de pénétration.
Beaucoup de technologies, à ce point, remplacent une autre technologie,
et c'est un autre point important.
Et puis, finalement, beaucoup de technologies deviennent des commodités.
A la fin de leur vie, elles deviennent pratiquement gratuites.
Chaque point représente une opportunité pour faire quelque chose ;
c'est une opportunité pour la technologie de changer.
Et même si vous ratez, vous savez, le premier boom de la Wi-Fi -
vous savez, la Wi-Fi a atteint le prix critique, a touché la masse critique,
mais n'a pas encore opéré la substitution, et n'est pas encore gratuite -
il y a toujours encore des d'opportunités à ça.
J'aimerais démontrer ce que je veux dire par là
en racontant l'histoire du DVD,
qui est une technologie qui est passée par tous les points.
Le DVD, comme vous le savez, a été introduit au milieu des années 90
et il était plutôt cher. Mais vous voyez qu'en 1998,
il est tombé sons les 400 $ ,et 400 $ était une barrière psychologique.
Et il a commencé à décoller. Et vous pouvez voir que les chiffres
commencent à grimper, le point d'inflexion caché, il décollait.
Le point suivant qu'il a touché, un an plus tard, c'était la masse critique. Dans ce cas
20 % c'est une bonne mesure pour la masse critique dans les ménages.
Et ce qui est intéressant là
est que quelque chose d'autre a décollé en même temps - le home-cinéma.
Tout d'un coup vous avez un DVD dans la maison,
vous avez une vidéo numérique de grande qualité,
vous avez une bonne raison d'avoir un grand écran de télévision,
vous avez une bonne raison pour un son Dolby 5.1.
Et peut-être vous avez des raisons pour commencer à les connecter,
et y inclure le reste de vos divertissements.
Ce qui est aussi intéressant, c'est de noter que Netflix a été fondé en 1999.
Reed Hastings est là. Il a clairement vu que c'était LE moment,
que c'était un point d'inflexion, qu'il pouvait en faire quelque chose.
La phase suivante qu'il a touchée est la substitution.
Vous pouvez voir qu'aux alentours de 2001, il a dépassé les ventes de VHS.
Et ici aussi, vous pouvez voir les implications dans le monde, en grand.
Netllix avait raison. le modèle Netflix pouvait capitaliser sur le DVD
d'une manière que les magasins de location de vidéos ne pouvaient pas faire.
Parmi les multiples attributs du DVD, il y a qu'il est très petit,
vous pouvez le coller dans l'enveloppe et le poster pour pas cher.
Cela donnait un avantage ; c'était un corollaire
de la montée de la technologie qui n'était pas évident pour tout le monde.
Et puis, finalement, le DVD s'approche de la gratuité.
Il y a une société appelée Apex, une entreprise chinoise sans marque,
qui, plusieurs fois l'année dernière, a été numéro un
de la vente de lecteurs DVD aux USA. Leur prix moyen, pour l'année dernière, était de 48 dollars.
Vous connaissez
le possible apocryphe ratage de Walt-Mart
sur les lecteurs à 30 dollars.
Mais ils deviennent très, très bon marché,
et regardez cette implication intéressante. Comme ils deviennent meilleur marché,
les marques premium, les Sony et autres, perdent des parts de marché,
et les sans-noms, les Apex, en gagnent.
Ils deviennent des commodités, et c'est ce qui se passe
quand les choses vont vers le zéro. C'est un marché très dur.
(rires)
Maintenant nous avons présenté ces quatre manières de regarder la technologie ;
ces quatre phases de la vie d'une technologie.
J'aimerais parler d'autres technologies ici,
juste des technologies sur notre radar et je vais prendre ces filtres,
ces quatre-là, comme moyen de vous dire
où en est chacune de ces technologies dans son développement.
Ce ne sont pas obligatoirement les 10 meilleures technologies
ce sont juste des exemples de technologies
qui sont dans chacune de ces phases.
Mais je crois que les implications, comme elles sont en train d'approcher
ces points, ces carrefours, valent la peine de s'y intéresser.
Commençons arec la séquence du génome [humain].
Comme vous le savez probablement, la séquence du génome
parce qu'elle se bâtit sur les ordinateurs - baisse en prix
à la manière d'une Loi de Moore.
C'est maintenant possible - il sera possible,
et si Craig Venter vient effectivement aujourd'hui,
il pourra vous en toucher quelques mots -
de séquencer le génome humains pour 40 millions de dollars à la fin de celte année.
C'est une différence avec les milliards d'il y a quelques années seulement.
Vous savez, la possibilité de capturer les outils de la création
se rapproche constamment.
Ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'en même temps, le nombre de gènes
qu'on découvre augmente très rapidement,
Chacun de ces gènes est un test potentiel de diagnostic.
Il y aura un jour
où vous pourrez faire faire des centaines de milliers de tests très bon marché,
si vous voulez savoir. Vous pourrez apprendre votre propre mosaïque.
Voici une autre technologie qui approche le prix critique.
C'est une recherche fascinante par l'OMS qui montre les effets
des médicament génériques et des composants et cocktails des médicaments rétro-viraux.
En janvier 2000, le prix était de 10 000 dollars, ou 27 dollars par jour.
Les génériques sont arrivés les premiers, d'abord au Brésil et puis partout,
et l'effet a été spectaculaire sur les prix.
Aujourd'hui c'est moins de 50 cents par jour.
Et c'est ce qui est intéressant si vous regardez l'élasticité du prix,
si vous regardez la corrélation entre ces deux-là,
comme les rétro-viraux baissent, le nombre de personnes que vous pouvez soigner
augmente radicalement. Et la fondation Clinton et l'OMS
croient qu'ils pourront soigner trois millions de personnes dans le monde en 2005 -
deux millions en Afrique sub-saharienne.
Et c'est en grande partie grâce à la chute du prix des médicaments,
Linux est un autre bon exemple.
Maintenant nous passons à la masse critique.
Ce sont maintenant des technologies qui touchent la masse critique.
Si vous regardez là, c'est Linux en rouge, et il touche 20 %
Il est intéressant qu'il ait déjà traversé une courbe auparavant,
mais ce n'est pas ce qui qui importe.
C'est la courbe bleue qui va être importante.
Mais vous pouvez voir la direction de ces lignes,
vous pouvez voir qu'à 20 %, c'est désormais pris au sérieux.
Ce n'est plus juste pour les geeks.
C'est pour ça que les gens à Redmond [Microsoft]
se réveillent au milieu de la nuit pour y penser.
(rires)
Une autre technologie que l'on voit tout autour de nous sont les véhicules hybrides.
Je ne sais pas si quelqu'un possède une Prius 2004, mais elles sont fantastiques.
Et si vous regardez les tendances, ici, aux alentours de 2008 -
et je ne pense pas que ce soit une prévision dingue -
elles feront deux pour cent des ventes d'automobiles.
Deux pour cent ne sont pas 20 pour cent mais dans le marché automobile,
qui a des cycles lents, c'est énorme, c'est un débarquement.
A deux pour cent, vous commencez à les voir partout sur les routes.
Et ce qui est intéressant au sujet du décollage des voitures hybrides
est que vous avez maintenant introduit les moteurs électriques dans l'industrie automobile.
C'est le premier changement radical dans la technologie automobile depuis 100 ans.
Et une fois que vous avez des moteurs électriques, vous pouvez tout faire :
vous pouvez changer la structure de la voiture comme vous voulez.
Vous pouvez avoir un freinage par régénération, vous pouvez avoir une conduite par câble,
vous pouvez avoir une carrosserie échangeable -
c'est une petite chose qui commence avec un hybride,
mais qui peut entraîner une toute nouvelle ère pour la voiture.
Vous avez peut-être entendu parler de la Voix sur IP.
De nouveau, ça sort de nulle part,
c'est un peu difficile à utiliser là tout de suite.
Il y a une société, créée par les fondateurs de Kazaa, appelée Skype.
Regardez ces chiffres. Ils ont commencé en août l'année dernière ;
ils ont déjà près de quatre millions d'utilisateurs enregistrés -
c'est la masse critique.
Et la même chose arrive du côté du fournisseur réseau.
Vous voyez le protocole internet prenant certains
standards traditionnels des télécoms. C'est un point de bascule -
si Malcolm est là, qu'il me pardonne - et cela va changer l'économie,
et la vitesse, et les acteurs dans l'industrie,
ça va ressembler un peu à ça.
Et finalement, le "libre". Le "libre" est vraiment, vraiment intéressant.
Le libre est quelque chose qui vient avec le numérique, parce que
les coûts de reproduction sont principalement gratuits. Cela vient avec l'IP,
parce que c'est un protocole tellement efficace. Cela vient avec la fibre optique,
parce qu'il y a tellement de bande passante.
Le "libre" est vraiment, vous savez, le cadeau de la Silicon Valley au reste du monde.
C'est une force économique, c'est une force technique.
C'est une force déflationniste, si l'on n'y prend garde.
C'est l'abondance, opposée à la rareté.
Le "libre" est probablement la chose la plus intéressante qui soit.
Et ici vous avez juste le nombre de chansons
qui peuvent être sauvegardées sur un disque dur.
Vous savez, il pourrait y avoir un [inaudible] film là,
mais c'est basique, toutes les chansons jamais créées, peuvent être sauvegardées
sur 400 dollars de support, en 2008. Cela enlève l'élément complet
l'élément physique, des chansons de la table.
Et vous avez vu les chiffres.
Je veux dire, vous savez, l'industrie de la musique implose
devant nos propres yeux, et Hollywood aussi est inquiet.
Ils font face à une force qu'ils ne connaissaient pas auparavant.
Et leur réponse est draconienne ,et pas nécéssairement
celle qui les sortira de là.
Et finalement, je vais vous donner le dernier exemple de "libre" -
peut-être le plus puissant de tous. J'ai mentionné la fibre optique,
son abondance tend à rendre la chose gratuite.
Ceci est le prix d'un appel téléphonique pour l'Inde par minute.
Et ce qui est intéressant , c'est l'année 1990,
quand c'était plus de deux dollars par minute.
L'Inde a toujours un système téléphonique régulé, comme nous.
C'était curieusement peu innovant, cela changeait très lentement
mais il y avait juste tellement de fibres là-bas,
vous ne pouviez pas les retenir, et regardez à quelle vitesse les prix ont chuté.
C'est sept cents par minute, dans la majorité des cas.
Et la conséquence des appels téléphoniques bon marché, des appels téléphoniques gratuits,
pour l'Inde, c'est le programmateur énervé, c'est le outsourcing.
C'est un des changements les plus spectaculaires de la mondialisation
et un des outils économiques les plus puissants
que l'on voit dans le monde aujourd'hui.
La force de l'Inde, et puis de la Chine, et de tous les autres pays
qui peuvent contacter nos marchés
et travailler avec nos entreprises - parce que les communications sont gratuites -
commence juste à se faire ressentir.
Et je pense que c'est probablement une
des plus importantes tendances technologiques que nous regardons aujourd'hui.
Je vous remercie.